you have to
get his elbow to go in
and then there must be weight on it
so you can't have his arm stay straight
and his elbow go down and not in
for neither down nor in
okay
so when he goes to grab
I'm going to use this motion here to
make his elbow go in and my weight is on
see it's elbow
in and my weight will drop on it down
in
and when I take on
it
[Music]
elbow going okay let's try okay
so where am I when my hand goes in
his other shoulders out of play
I don't want him grabbing one hand and
then the distal end of the lever and
then he'll disarm
I make that other hand oh out of the way
and not hide this sword in the angle
cancellation
so we have to all move
okay now
set up the mind he's going to keep
moving
there's my cut right
cut through in
in
um
[Music]
foreign
weapon disarming if if you get leverage
on my weapon I'm gonna lose it okay so
weapon retention I will claim the
Leverage
okay so when I come around here I
already move into that spot
okay
now when I come back don't do your cut
down here because you don't have
leverage on it okay you need some part
of the blade to cut but I should be down
by the edge so I'm controlling the
weapon okay
boom that's all I need for the cup
but a very very important part
is that he's moving
okay he keeps moving
he should not stay there
okay
no
so when his attack comes I take that
into uh the kazushi and that's where
he's gonna fall so where he's gonna fall
the cat you can't have uh let's say I
have my firearm here and if he goes to
grab my firearm I'm not gonna
do that stuff you see he goes to grab my
firearm and it's already moving out of
the way okay
so when I see him go to attack and see
how I move and then he keeps moving
okay so those two things he he's gonna
keep moving because I'm gonna let him
keep moving I'm gonna let him keep
moving because I played a hole for him
to fall into okay and then control as
much of the weapon as possible you can't
be down here because you'll be hiding
the cutting portion but this isn't going
to work
somewhere around here okay all right
let's try
so uh
here what I'm doing is an adhesion in
his on his palm okay but I'm using my
forearm okay it's not that I'm
leveraging this stuff I'm not I'm not
trying to leverage this okay
so the adhesion goes into the palm
okay that that's what's moving him
around that's what's opening them up and
then feel feel this okay here I am here
hi what feel in your palm hi you see
that
so most people only see the external so
they go okay elbow in then here and
you're not moving anymore and then they
go like that and you're standing
straight up
okay
so it's in his palm
move his palm around his palm around
boom
yeah and I'll get that little extra
Buck okay
a long
and I feel that connection you feel it
all right sorry okay so I'm feeling that
connection I don't want to lose it
I keep that connection
oh there it is
okay so too many of you are
going here here and you just stand in
there you see that that difference okay
keep him moving
feel the palm
okay all right let's try it again
[Music]
oh you're right
foreign
[Music]
you want to take that lightness back
into this technique
okay you're getting hard points in your
Technique but you should just fall into
all the empty spaces now all the time
foreign
when the weapon retention is at stake
You're Gonna Lose the weapon okay
and then what is this different than
your picturing I'm going to
expose
this wrist lock here this elbow time
okay so
you need his arms straight we need to
ground boom and that's your disarm okay
[Music]
time I'm using the moon neck not to kill
anything cut
here here this arm clearly
faith
this is a pass on that other arm
he's gonna push back in right so you
pass it
cut boom okay
let's try